monsieur Stéphane Lefol monsieur le
ministre merci de vous être déplacé
merci merci d'être avec nous ce matin
euh je vous avez donc nous vous
auditionnons puisque vous avez été
ministre entre 2012 et 2017 je je tiens
d'ailleurs à souligner que c'est un
record de longévité il faut quand même
le dire le ministère de l'agriculture
est un petit Matignon il y a une partie
du régalien qui est dédié il y a une un
enseignement une protection sociale une
fiscalité agricole c'est le ministère de
la des crises de la gestion des alas et
vous avez été ministre durant tout le
quinquen de François Hollande ce qui
nous intéresse particulièrement pour
cette commission c'est que c'est
pratiquement la moitié de la période qui
est examiné par la commission la
première moitié de la période
c'est-à-dire vous avez été le
ministre qui a tiré les conclusions du
constat d'échec des des premiers
objectifs fixés par un cofito moment du
Grenel de l'environnement le ministre
qui a le ministre de la mise en place du
plan écofyo 2 euh
et vous
avez en plus à l'époque avec le
rapporteur Dominique potier qui a qui a
émis un rapport sur cet échec cette
première politique publique et sa
transformation sur un sur un deuxième
plan et donc ce qui est important pour
nous c'est de vous entendre témoigner
sur bah la façon dont vous avez vécu
vous avez
interprété ces objectifs de
l'environnement non
atteint ça sera intéressant de savoir si
durant cette période durant le
quinena est-ce qu'il a un moment vous
avez compris que le plan écofyo 2 en
fait ne réussirait pas non plus si oui à
la faveur de quoi qu'est-ce que vous
avez constaté qu'est-ce que la dimension
interministérielle de ce plancofito est
importante aussi de comprendre comment
est-ce que vous avez appréhendé cette
cette interministérialité sach que je je
vous dis tout n je parle en mon nom mais
également nom de la commission il y a un
vrai sujet en fait sur la façon dont la
France euh parvient assez mal en fait à
conduire des politiques publiques à ce
point interministériel avec des gros
ministères des grosses administrations
centrales bref votre témoignage nous
importe je vais donc vous laisser la
parole pour un propos introductif d'une
dizaine de minutes pas plus le
rapporteur réagira on ouverra l'échange
aux membres de la commission et avant
cela je vous rappelle que cette audition
est ouverte à la presse qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée et euh que vous êtes
en vertu de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance
du 17 novembre 1958 relatif au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires tenu de prêter cment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité r que la
vérité je vais donc vous demander de
lever la main droite et de dire je le
jure je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre je je vous donne la parole
merci monsieur le Président je vous
remercie de m'inviter sur un débat qui
est toujours d'actualité et je vais
essayer en 10 minutes alors vous
m'interromprez he si je dépasse un tout
petit peu de vous rappeler ce que j'ai
fait pourquoi je l'ai fait et quel était
l'objectif stratégique je poursuis
suivait moi j'avais été vice-président
de la commission agricole du Parlement
européen j'avais parfaitement intégré
dans un rapport qui avait été publié
d'ailleurs le fait que pour baisser
l'utilisation et le recours au
phytosanitaire il s'agissait pas
d'interdire des produits sans penser à
changer les modèles de production chaque
modèle étant créé avec des conditions
pour qu'il puisse s'exercer le modèle
conventionnel avait sa propre
logique de production de spécialisation
et d'utilisation de phytosanitaire de
machinisme la première évolution verte
come on l'appelle c'est chimie machine
et
génétique c'est comme ça que ça s'est
construit ça a eu des résultats en terme
de production dans beaucoup de domaines
mais ça avait un inconvénient c'est que
ça a produit beaucoup de ce qu'on
appelle des externalité négative que ça
soit dans le domaine de l'environnement
que ça soit dans le domaine de la santé
et de la biodiversité
surtout comment j'ai abordé tout ça
quand je suis arrivé comme ministre la
première étape a été de négocier une
nouvelle pâqu et je le rappelle dans le
contexte puisquil faut toujours rappeler
les contextes la politique ne s'inscrit
pas en dehors des contextes historiques
dans lequel on agit à cette époque là au
niveau européen le commissaire siolos
avait posé les bases de ce qu'on a
appelé le verdissement de la PAC où il
visait comme objectif % de verdissement
sur les sommes allouées au verdissement
et quand je débute la négociation pour
être honnête et objectif on est autour
de 10 % à peine l'Allemagne pèse avec
d'autres pays pour faire en sorte que
les choix sur les le verdissement sont
des choix à tiroir avec des choix
nationaux avec à l'époque je me souviens
une douzaines de critères sur lesquels
chaque pays pouvait se positionner pour
choisir deux critères dans ces critères
il y avait par exemple méthanisation ce
qui faisait que l'Allemagne avait déjà
un critère d'office de cocher et il
suffisait qu'elle en choisisse un
deuxième sur les 12 pour pouvoir être
dans le cadre de ce qui était à l'époque
le verdissement tout ça a été changé le
poids de la France je le dis le poids de
l'agriculture française dans la
négociation budgétaire comme dans la
négociation de la politique agricole
commune a fait
revenir l'Europe sur une politique
agricole avec du verdissement et 30 %
consacrè verdissement
que ça soit avec les surfaces des
prairies permanentes maintenues et
préservées que ça soit sur la
diversification des rotations sur les
cultures végétales et que ça soit avec
la mise en place des surfaces d'intérêt
écologique ça c'est le premier point et
il a fallu le négocier j'ai écrit un
livre pour ceux qui veulent se rappeler
l'histoire où il y a même un
documentaire aussi sur la négociation de
la pack qui existe vous verrez que cette
négociation a été conduite avec cet
objectif là et nous l'avons
atteint à partir de là la deuxième étape
a été de faire une
loi pour intégrer la logique qui était
la mienne qui consistait à changer et à
faire évoluer les modèles de production
pour avoir un résultat en terme
écologique économique et social qui soit
à la hauteur de l'ambition que je
pouvais porter à ce
moment-là cette loi c'est la loi
d'avenir je regarde un collègue qui a
été un important participant des débats
de la loi d'avenir André chassigne avec
Dominique potier je rappelle que cette
loi a été votée par les socialistes on
était dans un gouvernement socialiste
par les communistes André chassen en est
témoin par les écologiste et par les
centristes de l'UDI de l'époque puisque
elle a été largement adoptée cette loi
visait à consolider l'idée que j'avais
de développer un nouveau concept qui
s'appelait l'agroécologie à l'époque
époque il était assez ancien en terme de
recherche mais nouveau en terme
politique et si je regarde l'évolution
aujourd'hui je m'aperçois que le GC
aujourd'hui reprend l'agroécologie comme
un des éléments nécessaires pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone et ça
c'est pas pas négligeable et vous le
voyez d'ailleurs aujourd'hui entre la
bio et le conventionnel on parle de plus
en plus de l'agroécologie c'est tant
mieux cette loi a visé cet objectif là
et à partir de là on l'a décliné après
le rapport qui a été présenté par
Dominique potier suite au Grenel de
l'environnement sur un premier plan
écofito qui avait connu quelques
éléments intéressants en travers des
fermes défi en particulier qui avaient
eu quelques résultats intéressants mais
la problématique c'est que ces résultats
intéressants dans les fermes desfi qui
avaiit euh laissé apparaître à peu près
une baisse de 10 12 % euh des phyos euh
c'était resté dans les fermes des des fi
c'est-à-dire 3000 fermes donc le plan
écofit de que j'ai
donc lancé avec le rapport de domin
potier visé à aller beaucoup plus loin
et à tenir compte de ce qui avait été
déjà fait par Michel Barnier après le
Grenel et de ce que nous devions faire
pour pouvoir réussir une baisse
quantitative de la consommation des
phytosanitaires je le dis la France est
le seul pays qui s'était donné des
objectifs quantitatifs faut pas
l'oublier non plus qui visait à partir
de 2015 jusqu'en 2025 et avec une étape
en 2020 a baissé de 25 % les
consommations de phytosanitair et aller
jusqu'en 2025 à une baisse de 50 % des
consommations de
phytosanitaires quels sont les trois
piliers de cette ce plan écofyo 2 et
c'est là que ça peut vous intéresser
pour savoir pourquoi quelque fois les
choses échouent il y avait trois
piliers le premier est Dominique ti en
était un initiateur c'était de se dire
3000 fermes défi qui réussissent à faire
baisser la consommation de de produits
phyosanitaire on doit passer à ce qu'on
a appelé et ce qu'il appelait à l'époque
le facteur 10 c'estd de passer de de
3000 à 30000 exploitations ce qui nous
faisait arriver à peu près à 10 % des
exploitations françaises qui étaient
dans un processus de baisse de la
consommation de phytosanitaire c'était
ça le premier objectif le deuxième
objectif c'était de développer des
alternatives à la chimie et ça c'était
l'intégration directe de la loi que nous
avions voté qui visé en particulier à
développer des systèmes alternatifs au
phytosanitair je pense au
biocontrôle je pense au biostimulant et
je pense à ce qu'on a appelé les NMPP
les fameuses molécules non préoccupante
qui nous a occupé quelques soirées et
quelques nuits en particulier avec André
chassigne
et le troisème pilier du plan c'était
les certificats d'économie de
phytosanitaire proposition qui m'avait
été faite par Marion Guillou au tout
début de mon arrivée dans le cadre du
projet sur l'agroécologie et qui
consistait à calquer ce qui existe avec
les certificats d'économie d'énergie à
le calquer pour faire en sorte que sur
les produits phytosanitaires on est un
mécanisme d'incitation à la recherche
d'alternative quand je regarde le débat
aujourd'hui sur les débats sur les phyos
vous avez tous entendu et tout le monde
l'entend de manière régulière oui on va
supprimer tel ou tel molécule mais il y
a pas l'alternative la vraie question
c'est de chercher à trouver des
alternatives c'est ça le sujet trème
pilier du plan écyto les certificats
d'économie de produits
phytosanitaires le principe je sais pas
si Christian wig est venu déjà à la
commission c'était de de donner comme
objectif une baisse je l'ai rappelé de
25 % de l'utilisation des
phytosanitaires mais de s'adresser aux
vendeurs de produits phytosanitaires
pour leur dire vous avez un objectif de
baisse vous avez la possibilité donc de
choisir et de promouvoir des Alternatifs
qui vont compter comme des certificats
c'estàd qu' vont aller dans le sens de
la baisse de l'utilisation de la chibie
des
phytosanitaires et si au bout de 5 ans
on a atteint l'objectif de - 25 % il se
passe rien si ce n'est le constat de la
réussite du plan ech phito 2 et si par
contre on a tap 25 % sur
l'ensemble de la vente de produits
phytosanitaires à cel il y a une taxe
qui s'appliquera qui avait été calculé
au début à 11 € le nou et qui avait été
après négociation avec la FNA qui a duré
pratiquement 1 an qui avait été acté à 5
€ le nu c'està-dire que si on dépassait
les 25 les si on avait pas fait les 25 %
de baisse de phytosanitaire il y avait
donc une taxe qui s'appliquait sur les
vendeurs de produits
phytosanitaires ce plan était
parfaitement cohérent avec un
financement à la fois sur les taxes sur
les pollutions diffuses d'autour de 40
millions d'euros et un supplément qu'on
avait rajouté de 30 millions d'euros un
plan de 70 millions d'euros pour engager
ce
processus en 2016 puisqueon est en 2015
hein le rapport de Dominique potier est
présenté en décembre 23 décembre 2015 au
Premier ministre c'était un cadeau pour
le ministre de l'Agriculture pour Noël
et cadeau que j'ai donc pris sous mon
sapin et j'ai présenté le plan le fin
janvier 30 janvier je crois 2016
ensuite il y a une concertation en juin
2016 tout le mois de juin
4700 remonté question et nous avons
présent présenter de manière définitive
le plan en octobre
2015 c'est ça qui s'est
passé avec les ordonnances et les
arrêtés qui allaient avec en particulier
sur les
CEPP je constate une chose et c'est là
que je je je je pointe un problème c'est
que nous avons eu droit à un recours sur
les
CPP déposé par les distributeurs de
phytosanitair à la fois cop de France
les
négociants négociants cop de France j'ai
vérifié et puis oui ouii absolument
recours qui a remis en cause le principe
des CEPP pour un principe juridique où
l'enquête publique avait été faite au
niveau de l'ordonnance aurait fallu
faire au niveau de l'arrêté enfin un
principe juridique bon très bien donc
remise en cause ce qui remettait en
cause fondamentalement l'outil numéro 3
du plan ecofyo 2 c'est-à-dire la
stimulation de la recherche des
alternatives à la
chimie on a réussi à repasser les CPP
dans le casre d'une PPL présentée par
Dominique potier à l'arrache et elle a
été adoptée dernier jour de 2017 du
quinena vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président du ministre de l'Agriculture
présent C ce matin avec
vous donc dans la
structure de ce plan il avait les CEPP
qui était une politique avec un
mécanisme de stimulation de la recherche
des alternatives j'aurais pu à l'époque
et c'était le débat augmenter les taxes
sur les phytosanitaires parce que
c'était ça aussi qui m'était proposé en
disant il suffit de monter les taxes sur
les phytosanitaires ça va coûter de plus
en plus cher et donc ça va obliger les
gens à chercher des alternatives on
sortait de se ou h crises agricoles he
vous avez parlé de crise agricole avec
le monde agricole à l'époque entre la
crise porcine la crise la crise de la
FCO les crises de la gripe aviaire la
crise de l'œuf qu'est-ce que il y en a
encore d'autres la crise des céréal la
crise du
lait j'ai plaisanté l'autre fois avec
une assemblée générale de de SIAL au
quand j'ai appris que la tonne de lait
était aujourd'hui à plus de 400 €ut faut
se rappeler que quand j'étais ministre
que Dominique potier était député à
l'époque on était ave une tonne de lait
à 260 240 € la
tonne j'ai présenté disant il était
temps que je parte pour que les prix
remontent mais là pour le coup sur les
CPP le fait que dans la loi égalim est
été
supprimé la taxe qui était prévue si on
nobtenait pas le résultat de 25
% puisque au lieu de d'avoir 5 € de taxe
on l'a mis à
zéro il va soit qu'à partir de là
l'incitation qui n'était pas une
sanction mais une incitation à la baisse
quels que soi les moyens à la fois la
baisse en quantité les changements qui
sont opérés et le ministre tout à
l'heure l'a rappelé on a
considérablement diminué tout ce qui
était toxique cancérogène et ça c'est un
point très important en terme qualitatif
il y a eu beaucoup de mollécules qui ont
été éliminées et il faut qu'on continue
comme ça mais au-delà de cette partie
qualitative sur la partie quantitative
il y avait un enjeu et il était lié au
EPP pour faire en sorte que on cherche
des alternatives et qu'on se retrouve
pas comme à chaque fois en disant
aujourd'hui si je supprime ou si
j'interdis un produit ben j'ai pas
d'alternative oui mais il faut à ce
moment-là se donner les moyens de
chercher les alternatives ça c'est le
premier constat que je fais je vous le
dis il est absolument nécessaire de
retrouver un mécanisme qui met en place
un système pour chercher des
alternatives et puis je termine sur un
deuxième point qui me semble aussi très
important c'est la question de la mesure
de ce qui se passe en terme de
d'utilisation des phytosanitaires le nou
qui est utilisé par la France et nous
sommes le seul pays à l'utiliser hein et
il a un défaut c'est qu'il prend les
quantités globales sans traiter la
question qualitative est-ce qu'on a des
produits qui sont de moins en moins
dangereux que ça soit pour la santé
humaine ou que ça soit pour la
biodiversité parce que ça c'est un point
très important la biodiversité et là le
NODU lui il prend toutes les quantités
qui sont utilisés je vais prendre un
exemple puisque j'ai regardé ça
maintenant euh si je prends la bio qui
utilise du cuivre en particulier pour
lutter contre toutes les maladies liées
aux champignons le cuivre est utilisé et
est intégré dans le cadre des nodus bon
vrai sujet est-ce que c'est ça
l'objectif est-ce que c'est ça qu'on
doit poursuivre parce que j'ai fait ce
constat et je vous laisse y réfléchir 2
secondes moi quand je suis arrivé en
tant que ministre il y avait 3 et demi %
de la surface agricole utile qui est en
bio quand on est quand je suis parti on
éta arrivé à peu près à 7 % on avait
doublé et aujourd'hui on doit être
autour de 10 %. comment se fait-il
qu'avec 10 % de surface agricole utile
française on arrive encore à avoir des
NODU qui augmentent alors qu'on a eu un
développement considérable multiplié par
3 de la surface en bio il y a quelque
chose sur la mesure qui ne va pas donc
si je résume ce que je viens de vous
dire 1 on ne peut raisonner la baisse de
l'utilisation et du recours à la chibie
que si on raisonne sur le changement de
modèle ça semble à peu près à qui
j'écoutis un peu les débats tout à
l'heure ça c'est un point majeur de si
vous voulez vraiment être efficace il
faut qu'il y ait un mécanisme qui oblige
à chercher des alternatives si vous
l'avez pas bah à chaque fois on retombe
sur le même problème c'estàd que l'idée
qu'une molécule qui est supprimée doit
être remplacée par une autre molécule
chimique non non si je regarde la
viticulture hier j'étais dans l'héros
puisque pour le 4 pour 1000 je rajoute
la question du stockage de carbone que
j'ai lancé en 2015 au moment de la COP
21 mais si j'étais dans l'éros hier
c'était en discutant avec le président
du conseil départemental qui me disait
que dans l'éros ils ont commencé par
mettre des incitations à au recours au
biocontrôle en particulier sur la
question des féromones pour limiter les
parasites et on le fait aussi dans la
SAR dans le Jannière ils ont commencé
ils étaient à 300 hectares aujourd'hui
ils sont à 12000 hactares de vigne qui
utilisent ce qu'on appelle joliment la
confusion sexuel et qui évite le recours
à des prits phytosanitaires et je sais
que dans le jère maintenant tu es là
pour le rappeler on le fait et c'est
tant mieux et même dans l'arbculture
donc tous ces éléments là sont des
éléments importants donc ce que je veux
vous dire et c'est pour ça que je suis
très heureux de pouvoir participer à
cette enquête c'est
un ne jamais oublier qu'on a besoin d'un
mécanisme
incitatif de il y a une question sur la
mesure hein le nou aujourd'hui a un
biais qui est qu'il faudrait qu'on
corrige et je rappelle que dans le plan
écofyo que Dominique ensuite a piloté au
niveau du comité qui était chargé du
suivi avait été indiqué qu'on
chercherait à regarder s'il fallait pas
modifier les indicateurs l'indicateur et
qu'on avait dit on garde le nu pour
l'instant mais on essaie de réfléchir à
un nouvel indicateur qui prennent en
compte c'était ce qui était évoqué tout
à l'heure par un député qui était
viticulteur quand même l'aspect
qualitatif de ce qui se passe toute
substance plus nocive remplacée par une
substance moins nocive que ça soit en
terme de santé humaine ou en terme de
biodiversité parce que ça j'y tient
énormément doit être un élément qui doit
être pris en compte voilà les deux
points sur lequels pour éclairer la
commission par rapport à l'expérience
que est la mienne je voulais à tout prix
venir ce matin jusqu'au jusqu'à Paris
retrouver une salle que j'ai connu et
des gens que j'ai connu et bien connus
aussi merci en tout cas merci à vous
monsieur le ministre vous avez largement
dépassé le temps de parole mais je vous
ai laissé siamant parce que c'était
passionnant euh de de vous entendre de
manière très très lisible très
argumentée refaire l'historique de ce
qui s'est passé ça reprend évidemment
beaucoup de choses qui ont été abordé l
des auditions de la commission d'enquête
mon le rapporteur je vous laisse réagir
en Stone jusqu'à midi et
15 faut ouis pas plus pas plus donc
monsieur le rapporteur merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre vous dire la joie
de de vous retrouver sur ce terrain qui
était une passion partagée c'est une
matinée importante parce qu'on a eu le
ministre en exercice aujourd'hui Marc
fenau et puis celui il y a 10 ans la
bande des 10 ans je vais V leur dire que
comme rapporteur et c'est le groupe
socialiste qui a l'initiative de cette
commission d'enquête c'est leur lecture
de d'une décennie qui en grande partie a
été perdu par rapport aux objectifs que
nousous étions fixés et on a pris 2013
le rapport de l'inserme qui alerte sur
la prévalence de certaines maladies
liées à l'exposition au phyau et on n'
pas pris le rapport mais c'est c'est
l'inser et le rapport et puis et puis le
plan
écofuto 2030 tel qu'il se prépare ainsi
que le règlement sûr qui va apporter des
éléments très importants à l'échelle
européenne l'ancien député européen que
vous savez que vous êtes savez très bien
que un règlement c'est plus puissant
qu'une directive pour mettre en
mouvement l'Europe sur ce sujet merci
pour ce retour sur votre engagement dans
la pack sur le plan social et écologique
son verdissement mais également la
répartition des aides la relocation des
aides avec des budgets très importants
en faveur de l'élevage et et de la
taille des exploitations la
reconnaissance des actifs et puis cette
loi d'avenir qui va inscrire une
révolution culturell et des dispositions
pratiques autour de de l'agroécologie
euh vous avez oubli vous avez oublié
c'est pas un reproche hein mais le
principe de phytopharmacovigilance qui
est qui qui est installé dans cette loi
et ensuite fondé oui voilà on propose de
l'étendre je le dis pour votre votre
fierté personnelle il va être on propose
de l'étendre à l'échelle européenne
tellement il a fait ses preuves en
Europe comme la reconnaissance du
biocontrôle qui a été sous votre
autorité et qui aujourd'hui devient une
norme qui va être inspirée également
l'Europe donc la France peut inspirer
l'Europe quand elle est quand elle est
elle-même inspirée je voudrais revenir
sur de façon plus plus incisif sur un
certain nombre de points sur la
relecture de de l'histoire il y a vous
avez dit pas que verdissement une loi
d'orientation et puis des dispositions
pratiques he 3000 rappelez une précision
hein c'était 2000 fermes quand vous
étiez au responsabilité on proposait de
les passer à 3000 et après on est revenu
en arrière enfin voilà c'était de de à
3000 et 3000 qui vont vers vers 300
c'est un peu le Triangle des Bermudes
cette cette ces 30000 fermes personne ne
sait ce que c'est devenu donc on on
décideune politique et puis et puis elle
est pas mise en œuvre alors justement
sur votre propre responsabilité parce
qu'il y a aucune complaisance dans une
commission d'enquête vous vous le savez
bien et on est là pour pour aller au
fond des choses il y a on est en 2015
vous avez rappelé l'agenda euh 2015 le
rapport sort il a été fini en 2014 il
est présenté en 2015 enfin on est autour
de novembre et et janvier 2000
2015 et dans ce rapport bien sûr les
choses sont freinées d'une part il faut
le dire par le recours de la FNA ça
c'est un point objectif on perd 6 mois
euh mais également par une hésitation à
l'échelle gouvernementale et on est là
pour se dire les choses je me rappelle
d'une déclaration du Premier ministre à
un congrès de la FNSEA qui semble mettre
le pied sur le frein par rapport à la
dynamique de l'agroécologie telle que
vous l'avez pensé est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire
euh avec la la rigueur qui convient une
commission d'enquête que il y a eu un
débat interministériel et que les
décisions n'ont pas toujours été prises
notamment à partir de la crise du lait
puis et la crise des serérales n'ont pas
toujours été à la hauteur de vos
espérances en matière d'autorité
publique pour pour mettre en œuvre cette
loi il y a pas que le recours de la FNA
il y a également une sorte d'hésitation
qui s'exerce au sommet de l'État à
matigon et à l'élsée je me
trompe quand moi je parle de
l'agroécologie à l'époque il faut quand
même que vous qu'on se rappelle Domi
potier et d'autres que les débats sur le
verdissement portent plutôt sur la
chimie
verte et je me souviens d'avoir des
débats que ça soit d'ailleurs au plus
haut niveau avec le président de la
République les premier ministres que ce
soit Jean-Marc Erraud et ensuite manuel
Vals sur le fait que pour moi la chimie
verte bien sûr ça a été une étape qui
consistait à faire du cracking sur les
molécules à avoir des politiques qui
permettaient d'avoir des molécules moins
dangereuse ou
d'utiliser ce qu'on imaginait aussi
après avec la biomasse et un certain
nombre de de de de produits autour de de
cette question de la chileie verte et
que l'agroécologie était quand même
complètement
ignorée ignoré il a fallu que et c'est
pour ça que la pâac et le verdissement
plus ensuite la loi et c'est la
légitimité que m'a donné le vote à
l'Assemblée nationale à l'époque qui a
permis ensuite de faire basculer une
partie de l'appareil même si au niveau
du ministère j'avais réussi à
convaincre les les directions hein
j'avais commencé très tôt à la FAO sur
la création d'un groupe sur
l'agroécologie à la chaîne
internationale et que j'ai eu des des
directeurs des directrices qui se sont
totalement mobilisé et qui continuent à
l'être aujourd'hui parceque j'en ai
encore rencontré une hier à Montpellier
c'est fantastique de voir la la
continuité qui existe aujourd'hui mais à
l'époque on part de loin de très très
loin et le débat que ça soit avec le
syndicalisme majoritaire ou alors avec
la Confédération paysane qui elle est
uniquement sur la question sociale
c'estàd la petite exploitation
l'agroécologie arrive pour essayer de
trouver une forme j'allais dire entre
guillemets de synthèse entre le
conventionnel et le bio et le débat et
la dialectique entre si vous êtes dans
le conventionnel ça veut dire que vous
faites rien pour l'écologie et si vous
êtes dans le bio vous faites rien pour
l'économie ce qui m'a d'ailleurs conduit
au niveau de la COP 21 quand je fais la
proposition là pareil de de créer
l'initiative 4 pour c'est du stockage de
carbone dans les sols pour rappeler à
tout le monde que les sols agricoles et
forestiers sont des puits de carbone
c'est pareil on est dans le débat entre
la Smart agriculture avec l'agriculture
de précision les satellites et tout ça
et puis les ONG qui considèrent que
l'agriculture pollue c'est tout le débat
qui continue d'ailleurs sur la question
de l'élevage bon donc c'est vrai que on
partait de loin et que le débat
politique vous le savez il est jamais
facile alors après sur la mise en place
écofyo de et le temps qu'on a passé j'ai
pas souvenir de débat intern où on
serait venu me dire il faut pas faire si
faut pas faire ça et j'imagine que ce
que vous rappelez de Monsieur le Député
sur uneinvention du Premier ministre
j'ai souvenir que dans la crise laitière
en particulier en 2015 et crise porcine
en Bretagne c'est pareil le prix du por
esttant remonté à plus de 2 € à l'époque
c'était à peine à 1 € le kilo hein
c'était catastrophique on était sur une
un comp texte extrêmement explosif au
niveau social et économique dans
l'agriculture il y a certainement eu de
la part du Premier ministre de l'époque
et peut-être à un certain niveau de
réticence à continuer à aller dans une
logique qui pouvait être contrariante
vis-à-vis des agriculteurs à un moment
où il connaissaient effectivement des
crises majeures parce que ces crisesl
elles ont été majeures mais mais je n'ai
pas eu moi après le vote de la loi
d'avenir qu'il a fallu aussi accélérer
hein puisque j'ai là dans les débat que
j'ai eu en interne et dans les rimes
qu'il a fallu obtenir sur le calendrier
législatif je voyais bien que si on
reporter la loi d'avenir après 2014
puisque elle est adoptée en 2014 c'était
tout qui prenait du retard tout et on
voit sur le plan écofyo alors il
rentrait dans le cadre du calendrier qui
était prévu hein quand même mais on est
quand même fin 2015 donc il nous reste
un an de mise en œuvre et puis après on
bute sur le recours et sur les débats
aussi que vous avez bien connu et je le
dis à la députée d'une circonscription
que je connais bien en Bretagne sur les
questions d'azote total faut se rappeler
que dans la loi il y a le principe de
l'azote total je vais pas expliquer ici
mais qui est très important et qui va
buter aussi sur une négociation qui va
durer et même si je suis resté 5 ans et
ben au bout des 5
ans à la fin il y avait en plus la
grippe aviaire 2e phase dans le
Sud-Ouest en fin 2016 début 2017 je m'en
souviens très bien et donc c'est vrai
que on n'a pas été assez j'allais dire
j'ai n'ai pas été assez sûrement à ce
moment-là encore plus punchy pour
pouvoir aller plus loin mais
heureusement que la loi d'avenir m'avait
donné quand même une légitimité
politique sur
l'objectif je reviens tout de même il y
a dans la loi d'avenir les G2 il y a par
ailleurs la proposition des 30000 fermes
en gros ça peut être la même chose c'est
individuel ou collectif il faut rentrer
en transition et il faut accompagner ça
qu'est-ce qui fait que ça se fait ça
prend pas comme ça ça aurait pu prendre
vous allez me dire qu'il y a eu des très
beaux gituxf que c'est un beau
laboratoire comme les fermes des filles
sont un beau laboratoire mais on est
loin de la massciification il faut se le
dire les yeux dans les yeux on a raté la
massification et là on va explorer deux
sujets un petit peu mais de façon plus
précise c'est d'une part
l'accompagnement par l'appareil des
chambres d'agriculture est-ce qu'elle
aurait dû être plus redevable est-ce
qu'on aurait dû avoir un autre type de
négociation avec avec elle pour obtenir
non pas seulement des promesses de
moyens mais des résultats la deuxième
question c'était le levier évidemment de
la séparation du conseil mais là vous
n'êtes pas en cause mais je vais vous
demander votre avis sur cette séparation
du conseil qui va intervenir plus tard
n'empêche que entre G2E et et et 30000
fermes euh même sous votre
responsabilité on voit pas un début de
déploiement massif al il y a les
élections il y a tous les T tous les
freins vous avez dit les crises et
cetera mais on on tarde à voir cette
massification se mettre en place il y
aurait fallu un mandat supplémentaire
pour le ministre le fol non je blague
c'est je l'ai quand je suis parti les
prix remonté donc il était temps que je
je m'en aille et au bout de 5 ans il y
en a qui étaient fatigué de me voir donc
il fallait savoir aussi arrêter sur les
g de jeu élément majeur et je va Mme le
lier à d'autres
éléments l'échec sur les deu oui c'est
l'échec de d'un impensé sur le
développement agricole autant sur tout
le reste moi j'avais créé un groupe
Saint-Germain et la création des J je
tout ça tout ça c'était pensé il y a une
question qui avait mal été abordée et
par moi en particulier c'était la
question du développement agricole
comment je relais il y avait les
Chambres d'agriculture qui avaient des
financements j'ai développé des
financements pour les onvars justement
pour stimuler les j Deuf on a eu au
début des résultats plus de 500 j2uf à
peu près alors je sais pas aujourd'hui
j'aimerais bien avoir des chiffres où on
en est il paraît qu'il en reste et ça
c'est un point important quelle était la
la philosophie c'est que si vous laissez
un agriculteur tout seul gérer une
transition aussi lourde de modèle de
production que le veut l'agroécologie
vous le mettez dans une difficulté
majeure la versersion au risque elle est
légitime puisque vous avez derrière le
revenu ou pas de revenu et que pour
l'agriculteur garantir son revenu c'est
la condition de la pérenité de son
exploitation donc les j cétait de se
dire on va raisonner une manière
collective j'avais repris l'idée toute
simple des G c qui avait mis en commun
le matériel agricole là j'avais dit on
va mettre en commun les objectifs
qualitatifs environnementaux pour faire
en sorte qu'on crée des dynamiques
sociales et économique 500 g deœu avec
des réussites vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le député mais aussi des freins
se parler franchement des chambres
d'Arure qui en ont pas fait un il y a
des endroits où j'ai pas pu d'autres ont
essayé d'autres ont mis quelques
pression pour ne pas faire donc c'est
vrai que sur le développement et même si
la partie onvar a été utilisée j'aurais
dû avoir une réflexion plus profonde sur
la manière dont quand on a de tels
changements à faire on on réfléchit à la
manière dont on va avoir les outils pour
les pour les pour les réaliser c'est
certain et là le temps qui m'a été
imparti après la réforme avec la loi et
2011 m'a laissé un peu sur ma fin et je
l'accorde aujourd'hui c'est un point sur
lequel il faut travailler je termine
juste sur un point sur les juf je voyais
par exemple aujourd'hui que le et à
juste titre la France propose de
développer des productions de de
protéines
végétales et de légumineuse c'est très
important mais on ne pourra pas
raisonner sur ce type de changement si
on raisonne pas non pas à l'exploitation
mais à l'échelle des j de ufs je
m'explique si vous voulez mettre plus de
rotation mais si vous imposez à des
fermes de 100 de 60 à 150 200 hactares
des rotations à l'intérieur de leur sol
agricole c'est beaucoup plus difficile
ensuite de valoriser les production et
les rotations de culture qui sont
installées alors que si vous le faites à
l'échelle de 1000 1500 hectares vous
avez des possibilités en particulier
pour les protéines végétales en
particulier pour le développement des
légumineuses de faire à partir de là des
choix économique extrêmement performant
pour diversifier les productions donc
les J pour moi c'est pas je remets pas
en cause l'exploitation individuelle au
contraire mais s'inscrit dans une
dynamique collective et comme on a mis
en commun le matériel avec les Gaek on
met en commun les grands objectifs
environnementaux et économiques c'est ça
l'enjeu et ça là-dessus je ne peux que
constater le le le défaut qui a été au
départ de celui de d'imaginer un
développement agricole capable
d'accompagner ces
changements vous évoquez plutôt les
cumas c'est ça pour la mise en comm des
matériels vous êtes oui je voulais
surout on a été ensemble à un salon des
cumas qui était dans l'innovation y
compris agroécologique il y il y a eu
une phase d'espérance quoi qui qui a été
qui est retombée et vous prenez votre
part de responsabilité sur l'absence
notre incapacité à évaluer et à corriger
le le mécanisme de développement ça
c'est c'est un impensé ouais tout à fait
c'estum oui je me permettis de préciser
juste après l'autre moyen massif de de
de d'inflexion des de la pratique des
sur les usages c'est évidemment le
conseil agricole marchand euh votre
ambition c'est donc les CEPP vous savez
très bien l'histoire vous avez réagi
vous avez même signé des tribunes sur le
sujet et tout c'est ça va être ruiné par
en 2018 le fait que votre ndu qui était
passé de 9 à 5 va passer à Z0 he c'est
bon donc on annule et de façon un petit
peu insidieuse par un décret ce
processus on peut pas faire et la
séparation de la vente qu'on avait
écarté à l'époque dans une décision un
dialogue cétait pas une bonne
recommandation j'avais pas porté dans
mon rapport vous l'aviez pas vous-même
suggéré vous aviez écarté cette
proposition et est amené par le débat
présidentiel elle va ruiner la dynamique
CEPP euh sans donner de résultats par
ailleurs puisque le bilan qu'on a fait a
Stéphane traver et montre que c'est un
échec donc on s'est privé c'est je
voulais vérifier que c'était votre
analyse on s'est privé d'un d'un moyen
qu'on avait à peine expérimenté et qui
n'a pas du tout qui n'a pas bon le
ministre feno nous dit qu'il est prêt à
réenvisager ça réintroduction mais on
est quand même sur 6 7 ans d'échec voilà
bon pas de pas de commentaire sur ce
point alors je peux seul commentaire je
peux faire monsieur le député c'est
celui que vous avez fait c'est
évidemment dans les trois piliers de
l'écofito 2 et on s'en souvient bien
l'un et l'autre il y avait je l'ai dit
3000 30000 c'est le facteur 10 il y
avait le développement du biocontrôle
des alternatives et même de
l'agriculture de précision et le
troisième pilier c'était les CEPP quand
vous retirez le le 3ème pilier il y a
toute chance de déséquilibrer un
tabouret hein vaut mieux avoir trois
pieds qu'en avoir que deux bon bah voilà
le résult ça c'est sûr pour moi ça fait
partie des sujets importants et sur les
cumas évidemment et vous avez bien fait
de me rappeler mais ça est revenenu avec
les Gaek parce que vous savez les parts
des Gaek lié au paiement redistributif
mais c'est les Cuma il mutualisent le
matériel et bien là il faut mutualiser
les enjeux environnementaux pour qu'il
soit
économiquement accepté et acceptable
i vous en êtes capable c'est des
réponses de de moins de 2 minutes
maintenant sur un sujet essentiel queon
n'est pas du tout abordé la loi
d'avenir prévoit une réforme du Code de
Santé Publique et donne à laness une
autorité qu'elle n'a jamais eu bon
est-ce que vous vous arrivez de
regretter cette disposition dites-nous
un mot pourquoi est-ce que vous prenez
cette disposition qui a une importance
capitale qui est remise en cause
aujourd'hui par la droite sénatoriale
qui est remise en cause par une partie
du syndicalisme qui m en cause par la
filière serérale enfin beaucoup de
personnes la remettent en cause et et le
doute c'est installé dans le débat
public sur cette réforme absolument
fondamentale euh certains pensent que
c'est une démission du politique que de
ne pas de renoncer à à contredire ou à
aménager une décision de l'an en matière
de gestion des risques euh d'autres une
autre école de pensée dit que c'est une
décision au contraire politique majeure
parce que c'est la seule qui peut nous
permettre de nous affranchir de la
pression des intérêts économique à court
terme avec du recul euh comment
jugez-vous cette évaluez-vous C cette
décision qu' aujourd'hui fait toujours
l'objet de discussion très vive euh
est-ce que voilà je je vais m'arrêter là
et puis j'auraai une question sur les
néonicotinoïde très rapide si on peut
avoir une réponse rapide ça permettra
dedessus très rapidement moi je prends
cette décision parce qu'il y a un moment
où en fait avant laness donnait des avis
renvoyit ça à la DGL qui reprenait les
avis de Lan qui les corrigeit les
changit renvoyit ça à lanc ce qui fait
qu'il y avait plein d'autorisation de
mise en marché qui étaient complètement
stoppé non pas parce queil y avait pas
il y avait pas un débat scientifique
mais il y avait un débat entre l'anè et
la direction la DGL et ça avait été
repéré par génération future comme un
élément qui faisait l'opacité du système
et le soupçon qui était porté sur le
ministre de l'Agriculture qui devait
cacher un certain nombre de choses donc
moi je me suis dit à ce moment-là c'est
exactement ce que je me suis dit et bien
on va rendre les choses transparentes
c'est l'ancèe qui aura la responsabilité
de la mise en marché aux politiques si
il y a un problème politique de poser
d'avoir ensuite la responsabilité du
retrait si une autorisation a été donnée
sur laquelle il y a un désaccord pour x
ou y débat ça c'est la responsabilité de
politique laissez croire que on aurait
pas l'ancesse c'est le politique qui
déciderait ce sont des centaines d'AMM
qui été traité tous les ans laissz
croire qu'un ministre de l'Agriculture
va s'occuper scientifiquement de toutes
ces AMM et c'est là qu'il aura son
pouvoir c'est ridicule je ne regrette
pas d'avoir transféré les autorisations
de mise en marché à l'anesse elle est
critiquée par certains ensuite ceux qui
sont dans l'idée de l'État profond qui
travailleraiit en dehors des des
politiques la responsabilité du
politique c'est de faire des choix
politiques c'est pas d'être sur des
choix techniques et technologiques tous
les jours c'est faux on demandera jamais
à un un ministre même si il a pu faire
des études scientifiques de passer
toutes ces ces matinées et ces
après-midis à regarder toutes les
autorisations qui sont données avec les
avis qui peuvent être donnés c'est ce
qui se passait même avec la DGL donc moi
j'ai clarifié les choses et franchement
le débat qui arrive c'est un vrai débat
politique hein c'est l'idée je vous le
dis qui a un état profond qui travaillit
en dehors de la responsabilité politique
la responsabilité politique elle doit
être assumée là où elle est essentielle
sur les choix stratégiques sur les
grandes questions de société sur toutes
ces questions techniques technologique
l'anèe a son rôle et la preuve moi j'ai
interdit le Cruiser OSR dès que je suis
arrivé en juin ou juillet 2012 sur la
base d'un rapport de l'anè et tout le
monde m'a félicité mais personne n'a
félicité à l'époque l'anè sur les
néonicotinoïdes vous
êtes plutôt hostile à la décision qui
est portée par Barbara pompelli de d'une
interdiction qui est programmée ce qu'on
constate surtout c'est que une fois que
l'interdiction est est programmée il y a
rien qui est mis en œuvre pour chercher
les alternatives c'est bon et et on
arrive à un ministre Julien Normandie
qui crée une réautorisation en disant il
faut 3 ans pour changer quand vous étiez
au responsabilité il y a eu il y a eu
une partie de ces 3 ans qui ont manqué
pour pour chercher des alternatives
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est grippé à ce
moment-là pour que alors contre votre
gré hein je connais les débats les
amendements que vous suggériez pour dire
peut-être si on peut et cetera ou plus
tard et cetera avec une certaine
prudence hein mais en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on est fait nettement
ou plus lentement une interdiction des
nonictinoïdes l'appareil de recherche
développement n'est pas mobilisé
suffisamment à temps alors 2016 c'est en
2016 l'interdiction he on peut faire peu
de GF parce qu'après on on attaque la on
est sur la campagne des présidentielles
c'est c'est une autre séquence quoi mais
en tout cas est-ce qu'on peut observer
que pour votre part et pour la part de
votre successeur Stéphane Travert on
prend pas les devant pour assumer les
conséquences de cette interdiction
programmée r à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure hein s'il y a pas un processus
qui s'engage scientifique de recherche
et d'accompagnement de ceux qui vendent
des produits pour chercher des
alternatives à chaque fois que vous
interdisez vous prenez une décision à un
moment T donné et T+ 1 quelle est
l'alternative ben les gens vous disent
il y en a pas alors c'était sur la
betterave he si je me souviens bien sur
la question des néoncitologiques où ils
sont revenus après décision d'indiction
de la même manière je le dis que sur le
glyphosate le l'idée qu'on allait
interdire et puis maintenant on
s'abstient bon et puis on se contente
très bien du fait que ça va être
prolongé pour 10 ans mais ça c'est des
sujets ça revient au début du débat que
nous avons eu si on ne stimule pas et si
on n pas une alors là c'est la politique
une politique volontaire pour chercher
les alternatives vous n'en n'urez pas je
disais tout à l'heure sur les féromones
et la confusion sexuelle sur les vignes
je pourrais parler aussi sur les vignes
de l'utilisation des herbicides jusqu'à
il y a très peu de temps aujourd'hui on
a des vignes en herbé et puis personne
ne discute de savoir si c'est bien ou
pas bien pour la vigne alors à une
époque Dominique tu t'en souviendras et
tu es dans une région pas loin où il y
avait des vignes dès que tu avais de
l'herbe ça veut dire que tu étais un
mauvais
viticulteur et moi j'ai créé un jig de
œuf et grâce à des viticulteurs je m'en
souviendrai au px loup qui s'appelait
les
enerbeur j'avais dit à l'époque je
connais beaucoup d'emmerdeurs mais des
enerbeurs très peu et bien aujourd'hui
la vigne utilise l'enlerbage et évite à
ce titre des consommations d'herbicides
qui dans le domaine viticol je peux vous
dire c'était des nodus mais alors des
gros nodus
hein merci monsieur le ministre avant
d'ouvrir le le l'échange avec les
membres de la commission j'ai moême une
question à vous poser
euh il il est un point qui a pas mal été
abordé les travaux de cette conviction
c'est la responsabilité de l'aval vous
avez euh vous avez évoqué de manière
brillante euh les G gu le fait que c'est
à une échelle territoriale que on peut
avoir les volumes qui permettent d'avoir
les débouchés économiques volume
effectivement qui permettent du coup de
saturer des équipements de
transformation de conditionnement et
cetera cela dit s'il y a pas les achats
si au niveau je parle de l'agroindustrie
de la grande distribution de l'achat
public euh les agriculteurs vont pas les
inventer les déboucher il y a un vrai
vrai sujet aujourd'hui le le réseau défi
nous a dit les verrouillages les là où
le le recours phyo baisse le moins c'est
pas pour des raisons agropédoclimatiques
c'est même pas par filière c'est quand
il y a verrouillage par le marché c'est
C des charges est-ce que au cours de vos
responsabilités il y a eu un moment
est-ce qu'à un moment donné ce point là
est apparu et est-ce
que bah bon vous avez répondu à mes
question non mais merci non sur cette
question précise monsieur le Président
il y a pas eu à un moment un débat de ce
type là sur la question des cofit 2
vraiment mais je l'entends parfaitement
et je pense que de toute façon peut pas
dire il y a un frein c'est c'est c'est
un contexte aussi culturel qui fait que
il y a des freins celui-là doit en être
un mais à l'époque où on est que je vous
l'ai dit on est dans un total changement
en terme de paradigme agricole on essaie
de de mettre autre choses en place et ce
sujetl mériterait d'être vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président beaucoup plus
investigué en tout cas pour ce qui me
concerne moi j'ai pas de souvenir de de
de ce type de débat merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président
chassigne merci bon d'abord je voudrais
saluer le cette révolution qu'on
pourrait quasiment qualifier de
copernicienne qui a été engagé par
Stéphane lefolle comme ministre de
l'Agriculture j'ai l'occasion de le de
le signaler j'avais d'ailleurs utilisé
pour résumer une citation deoreux
néchard qui avait été reprise dans un
ouvrage écrit par Stéphane lefolle à la
suite l'inaccompli bourdonne de
l'essentiel l'inaccompli bourdonne de
l'essentiel c'est pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans le
bourdonnement il y a les grandes lignes
qui ont été fixées qui ont fait de
Stéphane Lefol le
jean23 de le jean23 de l'agos écologie
si on peut dire mais c'est V maintenant
on est dans le dur donc je vais me
limiter une observation enfin
observation question et ça m' sembl
extrêmement intéressant j'avoue je n'ai
pas pensé avant mais je pense que le
président et les rapporteurs avaient
avait imaginé ça c'est le rôle de la
réponse collective on est trop souvent
trop souvent dans la réponse
individuelle de l'agriculteur face à ces
problématiques et il est là avec tout
tout ce qu'il y a je veux pas développer
bien sûr sur la rentabilité sur il y a
la famille derrière il y a les pressions
de la
société c'est vraiment une une une
charge mentale extrêmement forte or or
les G2 avait une faculté effectivement
de mobiliser de de faire du collectif je
donne deux exemples qui sont liés
directement directement au sujet que
l'on a y a un GIE un G2E qui avait été
fait dans le département de puid d'omme
entre des des jeunes agriculteurs
céréaliers de liimagne qui font purement
des céréales et des
éleveurs des éleveurs du césalier qui
eux produisaient des engrais organiques
par leur élevage ça on a un exemple
d'une approche collective qui peut
permettre apporter des réponses et je
pense que c'est dommage faudra qu'on
faudrait qu'on fasse un bilan là-dessus
c'est dommage que ces G2E ont pu ont pu
être freinés ou n'ont pas été prolongés
enfin à vérifier deuxième exemple on a
des abattoirs qui ont des difficultés
ces abattoirs produisent de la poudre
d'os ou peuvent produire de la poudre
d'os de de la courne broyée qui
constitue aussi qui cons aussi des
ingris organiques de qualité de qualité
et et il pourrait y avoir des G2 œufs
avec aussi des des des agriculteurs des
céréaliers pour limiter l'usage de
phytosanitair de pesticides par exemple
au profit de de de ce type d'engraé donc
l'approche collective me semble
importante importante à à souligner donc
je rajoute rien par rapport par rapport
à ce qui a été dit mais ça me semble
important et de la même façon faire
appel à des agences ou comme comme c'est
le cas hein pour c'est c'est pour
ministre de l'Agriculture d'aller
trancher sur certaines sur certaines
choses je l'ai embêté emmerd puisquil
employait le mot tout à l'heure pendant
des années Stéphane Lefol pour qu'on
puisse de nouveau consommer hein de la
fraise de veau parce que c'est un plat
spécifique de chez moi bon
l'autorisation a été obtenue mais je
pense c'était pas le rôle de
l'agriculture de répondre à des
questions écrite successive d'André
chassigne pour qu'on puisse lever cette
difficulté merci monsieur le Président
chassigne je me permet un toute petite
précision monsieur le ministre et les
débats que nous avons des discussions
que que j'ai beaucoup avec le rapporteur
que nous avons eu en commission à propos
de cette loi de 2014 et de la fusion au
niveau de l'ANC de l'évaluation de
l'analyse du risque ce que vous avez dit
était très très clair
et je crois pas du tout qu'il a jamais
été remise en cause ce principe de de de
bon sens de gestion administrative avec
un travail qui en gros été fait en
double la question de la responsabilité
du politique porte sur des cas
d'interdiction de mise en
marché dans qui qui sont beaucoup moins
nombreuses que les cas d'autorisation
là où se pose la question du calcul
bénéfice risque la question de savoir
qui fait ce calcul et qui est
responsable de ce calcul devant devant
la société c'est en cela où je considère
que il peut y avoir des nuances et des
échanges j'app juste cette précision ça
ne remet pas du tout en cause encore une
fois
l'essentiel
madame merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous avez
évoqué donc tr tris piliers et donc l'un
des piliers le développement des
alternatives à la chimie nous sommes
tous d'accord avec ce concept sachant
que le développement des alternatives
implique que ces alternatives soient
utilisables par nos agriculteurs dans
les points qui ont été évoqués par les
différentes filières que ce soit
l'arboriculture donc je pense à
l'association nationale pomme pooire que
ce soit bref je vais pas cité
obligatoirement toutes les filières il
est évoqué que certaines techniques et
notamment de de biocontrôle existeraient
dans des pays voisins ne seraiit pas
utilisé dans le notôre il est également
évoqué lorsque l'on parle des fois de
molécules qui ne peuvent plus être
utilisées dans l'agriculture française
que ces molécules ne peuvent plus être
utilisées non pas parce qu'elles ont été
interdites mais parce qu'elles n'ont pas
été
réhomologuées donc lorsqu'on entend tout
cela on se dit que l'une des questions
qui se pose un notre modèle agricole
français c'est la question de
l'homologation des techniques alors que
ce soit sous forme de molécule que ce
soit sous forme de prédateur d'insectes
et autres aujourd'hui on n' pas de
réponse à cette question donc est-ce que
vous du moins moi j'aurais bien aimé
vous vous vous entendre
sur pour vous est-ce que l'absence de
solution est entre autres liée à
l'absence de renouvellement des
l'absence des renouvellements des
autorisations de de molécules voire à
l'absence de de de création de demande
pour des nouveaux nouveaux produits et
ce avec les firmes qui ne font pas les
demandes correspondantes donc moi
c'était ma c'était vraiment ma ma
première question où comme on n pas de
demande des firmes qui mettent au point
ces produits ou qui ont mis au point ces
produits est-ce que c'est l'une des
l'une des raisons ma deuxième question
est une question un peu plus générique
et qui lié à on va dire l'un des
principaux points de de de votre période
en exercice ça se caractérisait d'abord
et avant tout par la mise en œuvre de ce
qu'on pouvait appeler la nouvelle pâack
et avec avec la mise en place d'un d'un
nouveau logiciel pour la PAC lorsque
vous étiez en position le temps
l'énergie mise à la liée à la mise en
place de cette nouvelle pâack est-ce
qu'il a eu des conséquences sur
l'ensemble des autres politiques
agricoles pendant lorsque vous étiez en
fonction je vous
remercie monsieur le
ministre pour répondre à André chass
d'abord je resterai laïque même si j'ai
beaucoup apprécié d'être comparé à Jean
23 euh sur les j2f je je considère
qu'effectivement juste un élément
stratégique et économique si on veut
réussir à avoir une alimentation qui
soit accessible à tout le monde et
diversifié pour tout le monde parce que
on peut considérer qu'il y aurait des
produits qui seraient réservés aux plus
pauvres et la diversification et la
richesse de l'alimentation à à ceux qui
ont plus de moyens on veut pour pour
tout le monde un accès à une
alimentation riche et diversifiée il
faut intégrer dans le domaine de
l'agriculture que si la mise en
production nécessite énormément de
besoins de financement vous allez avoir
des difficultés à obtenir le résultat
attendu diversification accessible à un
prix pour le plus grand nombre en même
temps que vous obtiendrez un revenu pour
les agriculteurs on peut pas continuer à
demander aux agriculteurs d'avoir des
besoins de financement pour pouvoir
lancer des exploitations et de la
production qui soit déconnecté de la
capacité qu'on a au bout à leur offrir
un prix donc ma stratégie de
l'agroécologie a toujours été de dire
baissons le besoin de financement
utilisons la nature dans ce cas là de
gratuit pour pouvoir limiter ce dont on
a besoin pour produire en agriculture et
c'est pour ça que sur les questions
d'agriculture de précision satellitaire
et tout ça si on redemande aux
agriculteurs d'aller investir encore une
fois dans d'autres trucs pour avoir des
renseignements et que ça coûte plus cher
on est toujours en train d'alimenter la
pompe à emprunt qui lui-même nécessite
des résultats à la hauteur pour pouvoir
rembourser les empreunts qu'on a n même
suscité pour produire c'est vraiment le
sujet et les J2 dans ce cadre là sont
essentiels hein de l'ineachevé bourdonne
l'essentiel pour reprendre la belle
formule c'est la vérité et ce qu'on a vu
sur les j des ufs pour ceux qui ont été
lancés et il y en a qui reste c'est
monté jusqu'à 1 million on est passé de
de il y avait 500 on est jusqu'à 1000
12200 je sais on me dit qu'il en reste
aujourd'hui beaucoup mais j'aimerais
bien effectivement moi-même je je je
vais m'en occuper je vais regarder où on
en est mais c'est essentiel donc ça
c'était pour répondre à à André chass il
a raison c'est là il y a une clé
économique écologique et social parce
que laisser les agriculteurs tout le
temps tout seul supporter le risque et
supporter les choix à
faire c'est extrêmement lourd alors que
quand ils sont dans un J de UF c'est une
force frapp c'est une capacité à
négocier c'est une capacité vous l'avez
dit monsieur le Président une fois que
je fais de la production en rotation à
développer de la transformation prenons
l'exemple de ce qui a été fait avec le
cols et Sabin à l'époque il lance la
production de colza dans le cadre du Gat
avec les États-Unis qu'est-ce qu'il en
découle de cette production de col de
l'huile et des
tourau si vous lancez des rotations dans
lequel vous avez de la production de
protéin végétal et en particulier
utilisation de légumineuse vous faites
deux choses à la fois vous pouvez
nourrir votre élevage de manière
souveraine et deuxièmement vous pouvez
fixer de l'azote dans les sols et vous
évitez que la France importe de l'azote
minéral c'est-à-dire du gaz mais si je
raisonne exploitation par exploitation
le choix il est extrêmement risqué si je
risonne à l'échelle d'un J2 UF le choix
devient assumé collectivement et la
dynamique se crée si on fait pas ça on
on n'aura pas pas les objectifs qu'on
veut atteindre en terme de souveraineté
en terme d'écologie en terme de social
en terme de revenus ça c'est le premier
point et je vraiment je là-dessus je et
je l' dit tout à l'heure le vrai échec
c'est de pas avoir mis en place un
système de développement qui accompagne
ça ou qui fasse comprendre ça sur votre
question madame la députée il y avait
deux questions la première c'était sur
est-ce que et je pense que le ministre
fen a très bien répondu là-dessus il y a
des non renouvellements qui sont liés au
fait que les entreprises intègrent
parfaitement les qui peut y avoir et
surtout l'étroitesses des marchés qui
fait qu'ils n'y ont pas intérêt soyons
honnête hein ils se ils se délestent de
molécules qui trouvent pas forcément de
de grands débouché donc ça les intéresse
plus donc il renouvelle pas les les
autorisations de misise en marché ça
c'est vrai mais comme il l'a dit est-ce
que c'est pas aussi un processus qui
fait que les molécules les plus
dangereuses ou les moins utile
disparaître de manière mécanique et
logique sur la clause miroir il l'a dit
aussi et je partage parce que moi j'ai
j'ai été souvent interpellé là-dessus
les autres seraient des tricheurs et
nous nous serons que vertueux quand vous
êtes ministre de l'Agriculture vous
allez voir les Allemands ils vous disent
que c'est vous qui trichez ou les
Espagnols de la même manière bon alors
dire non c'est pas vrai je pense que
ladessus il faut quand même qu'on fasse
un bilan qui soit objectif et qui
permette de mettre tout le monde à
niveau qu'est-ce qui est de la
réglementation européenne et plus on
aura de réglementation européenne dans
le sujet moins il y aura de distorsion
de concurrence c'est
et il faut pas toujours alimenter cette
idée que les autres ce sont des
tricheurs et que nous on serait
uniquement vertueux parce que je vous le
dis les autres il pensent la même chose
de nous donc il faut dire l'Europe a une
responsabilité d'harmonisation et ce que
tu as vous avez dit Monsieur le Député
deinique potier sur l'idée que le
biocontrôle est en train de passer à
l'échelle européenne alors que nous
avons été à l'initiative de lancer c'est
très important ça c'est des points très
importants on partage ensemble les
règles et on évite d'avoir de la
distorsion ce qui it ce qui a fait
d'ailleurs que dans la négociation de la
PAC j'avais refusé les hypothèses qui
étaient celle qui consistait à avoir des
critères de verdissement que chaque État
choisissait et alors là on aurait été
dans la distorsion de concurrence totale
faut pas faire ça faut rester sur une
logique où on est sur un marché où tout
le monde peut aller donc on doit avoir
les mêmes règles et après vous avez posé
une deuxième question c'était
[Musique]
sur Madame la Députée je voulais que
c'est intéress c'était la Cluse num ça
je me souviens mais la deuxième
c'était oui
d'accord c'est
ça voilà donc on négocie la PAC elle est
adoptée je le crois à Luxembourg et au
Parlement européen en à l'été
2013 on a un accord au conseil en
février mars à Luxembourg
2013 après elle se met donc en
application en 2014 et entre 2013 2014
il va arriver quelque chose que j'avais
pas prévu je vous l'avoue c'est là
purement
européen l'Europe conteste les surfaces
éligibles françaises et considère qu'on
a une erreur je vous le dis quand même
de 08 % ou 0,6 je sais plus entre donc
je 06 08 contestation sur surfac qui
sont éligibles pour des histoires dans
une exploitation construisez un hangar à
un moment vous utilisez tant de mètres
carrés ils étaient peut-être igibles
avant ils le sont plus après les
corrections ne sont pas faites donc on
s'engage dans une négociation sur la
purement à purement de 3 milliards
d'euros hein
euh budgétairement à l'époque je peux
vous dire que du côté de Bery c'était la
joie et donc on négocie avec la
Commission européenne de faire ramener
la pururement de 3 milliards à 1
milliard d'euros avec une contrepartie
qui était de refaire toutes les
orophotos
c'està-dire la photographie des
exploitations à l'échelle française pour
redéfinir la se éligible et quand on
s'est engagé dans ce processus là on a
perdu du temps et ça nous a mis dans une
pression énorme sur les paiements du
premier
pilier qui ont été reportés sur les
paiements du deuxème pilier et sur les
MAEC et sur les agricultur bio sachant
que entre-temps je le dis quand même on
a doublé les sommes pour les Maek et que
j'ai créé les Maek système qui
continuent à exister je l'espère puisque
c'est dans le même esprit qui j'ai de U
c'estd c'est pas simplement je fais
quelques chose à un endroit non j'essaie
de développer un système vertueux et la
bio qui était sur le deuxième pilier
parce qu'on a fait le choix de verser en
temps et en heure les aides du premier
pilier et donc on a reporté avec des
avances pour pour la bio pour les Maek
la mise en œuvre du deuxième pilier et
ça ça a été je le dis un casse-tête
alors là pour le coup mais
alors politiquement et pour une
administration comme l'administration
française qui s'est retrouvé à être
obligé de refaire toutes les
photos un sujet où on a ét obligé
d'embaucher je sais plus combien de
personnes dans toutes les dans toutes
les DDT et au niveau des drafs pour
arriver à à à revoir et refaire sous le
parcellaire et ça nous a mis dans une
situation de difficulté majeure c'est ça
qui a été la cause de la difficulté de
la mise en œuvre de la pack on la
négocie elle est prête verdissement
deuxème pilier avec les régions parce
que ça aussi il y a eu de la
décentralisation mise en place des Mac
et Booum on se retrouverappé par la
patrouille de la purement pour 3
milliards d'euros on négocie à 1
milliard mais on s'engage à refaire
toutes les ortophoto et là entre 2014 et
2015 c'est une course mais terrible avec
un risque qui était apocalyptique c'est
qu'on ne puisse pas verser les aides du
premier
pilier merci il est 12h13 je vais
prendre les trois dernières
interventions et je vous demanderai
monsieur le ministre d'y répondre en en
ayant un mot de
conclusion madame pochon puis monsieur
martinau puis monsieur bord non madame
pochon de question peut-être déjà été
abordé Monsieur
Martin merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre merci merci pour
votre intervention ce matin et je suis
fier justement de voir que la SAR est
bien représentée ce matin j'en profite
et justement de saluer votre travail que
vous avez fait sur
l'agroécologie et justement votre votre
intervention qui qui dit la vérité et
qui justement dérange quelquefois parce
que je tiens à rappeler enfin je sais on
me dit on me dit faut pas que je le dise
tout le temps que je suis producteur en
bio mais justement en bio on a aussi on
fait on fait des choses qui qui
quelquefois me dépla plaise
personnellement et justement vous l'avez
dit et ça sera le sens de ma question
sur les NODU qu'est-ce comment on
pourrait justement mettre en avant les
actions des agriculteurs sans toujours
parler du nombre de traitements du de la
quantité de produits et je m'explique
hein sur un traitement très très précis
comme la tavelure par exemple où vous
avez un produit de synthèse chimique qui
va vous couvrir pour 40 mm et et environ
10 15 jours sans intervention en bio je
suis obligé de traiter tous les 10 15 mm
avec du cuivre et comment je fais ça
veut dire que mes voisins mes riverins
depuis que je suis bio je traite
beaucoup plus et et ça dans l'opinion
publique les gens qui sont riverins de
nos vergers et ben franchement ils sont
inquiets et donc comment on peut les
rassurer que oui ok on fait du bio mais
que bah de toute façon on passe quand
même traiter et ça veut pas dire que ce
n'est pas non plus nocif je le voit bien
avec les moutons un truc un détail très
bêtein on ne peut pas laisser pêtre nos
vergers avec des avec avec des moutons
dans les vergers bio parce que le cuivre
est phytotoxique et donc vos animaux
passeront l'ARM à gauche voilà je vous
remercie merci chers collègu monsieur
Borda puis madame Thain
oui merci monsieur le ministre c'est une
une intervention assez brève
et dans dans le suiv de ce que vous avez
dit parce que j'en ai évoqué le sujet
souvent avec mes collègues notamment sur
la problématique des des petites
filières des des plantes orpheline
qui se retrouve dépourvu de produit et
donc moi j'ai l'exemple en Côte d'Or de
la production de moutarde qui est en
fait suspendu à une molécule ma collègue
Laurent ceddel pourrait vous parler de
la la production de la cerise et on a
cette difficulté c'est de se dire mais
qui peut accompagner qui peut prendre en
charge tous les besoins d'innovation de
recherche pour toutes ces petites
filières ces petites cultures parce que
si on les perd on perd l'identité de nos
région on perd de la valeur ajoutée et
donc c'est un une vraie problématique
voilà donc c'est une vraie problématique
aujourd'hui pour nous de se dire comment
on peut accompagner avoir des vrais
moyens financiers si les industriels ils
ont aucun intérêt à à trouver un produit
pour la moutarde ou pour la serise mais
comment on peut faire voilà c'était une
remarque et jamais oublié ce ce sujet
des des petites
cultures merci madame
Thomas merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je
voulais et bien revenir avec vous sur
votre travail fondateur au ministère de
l'Agriculture pour construire nos
objectifs de réduction des produits
phytosanitaires et revenir avec vous en
fil rouge sur le rôle de
l'anè c'est sous votre ministère en 2014
que la décision d'autorisation de mise
sur le marché a été transféré du
gouvernement à l'ansè ce basculement de
l'autorité politique à l'autorité
scientifique et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure dans un contexte lourd de
soupçons parfois portés sur le décideur
politique en l'occurrence le ministre de
la l'agriculture je voulais rajouter une
question à ce qui a déjà été abordé tout
à l'heure et notamment sur le fait que
ce procédé était-il aussi un moyen pour
vous en tant que ministre de
l'Agriculture de pouvoir trancher par la
science des arbitrages qui pouvaient
être conflictuel avec vous votre
ministère et certains de vos collègues
notamment à l'époque la ministre de
l'environnement de l'énergie et de la
mer première question et puis euh est-ce
que dans ce contexte aujourd'hui actuel
de remise en
cause de la décision par l'ansè est-ce
que quand l'autorité de l'ansè est
remise en cause pensez-vous que cela a
une influence directe sur nos objectifs
de réduction à 50 % de l'utilisation des
produits
phytosanitaires tout à l'heure le
rapporteur potier l'a dit le doute
s'installe dès lors que le ministre de
l'agricultur de l'agriculture ou qu'une
ancien ou qu'une ancienne présidente de
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale ont par
leur déclaration disylé un sentiment de
remise en cause du rôle décisionnaire de
l'anè est-ce que dans un contexte de
responsabilité politique pensez-vous que
cela influe sur nos objectifs de
résultats et puis dernière
question je je souhaite revenir avec
vous sur un rapport qui a été publié par
l'anè au mois de mars dernier sur la
présence en quantité élevée de plusieurs
métabolites dans l'eau dans l'eau
potable je voulais savoir quelle
décision politique de précaution devrait
être prise selon vous pour faire face à
cette alerte qui nous semble majeure je
vous
remercie monsieur le ministre bon
écoutez je vais essayer de répondre au
TR questions je je
pense chers député de la Sarte et et
producteur que il y a je l'ai dit à
réfléchir la manière dont on mesure
l'impact des produits qu'on utilise que
ça soit les if les QSA ou les NODU
aujourd'hui qui sont des mesures qui
tiennent et qui ont un sens je trouve
que on on on loupe quand même l'objectif
quel est quel quel doit être notre
objectif moins de chimie dans
l'environnement ça c'est le premier
objectif moins de molécules et en
particulier les molécules persistantes
parce que celles qui restent et qui ne
disparaissent pas rapidement et il y en
a beaucoup on sait que on a encore des
traces d'AC
dans les naréatiques on sait que sur des
métabolites là dans l'eau il y a donc
objectif
changer ce que nous sommes en train de
laisser dans l'environnement et baisser
toutes ces molécules c'est la le premier
point donc il faut que le nou intègre ça
et pas simplement les quantités qui sont
utilisé le deè point c'est que il faut
que ça soit mesuré aussi à l'onde de la
biodiversité puis que vous le savez
c'est un sujet là moi qui me préoccupe
la biodiversité a baissé je disais un
petit édito de Gaspar kedy qui a
découvert les les les Lomb briques
depuis peu et si je l'avais eu à
l'époque je l'aurais sûrement solcité
pour défendre avec moi les lombriques
mais maintenant il a découvert ça et il
en est très heureux et il écrit
tellement bien que il fait des très
beaux articles mais la biodiversité dans
les sols la biodiversité au-dessus des
sols
c'est un élément majeur et c'est là que
la Pâque devrait
intégrer un élément de biodiversité dans
les sols et à proximité des sols comme
un élément de verdissement et ça se
justifierait d'ailleurs à ce moment-là
le fait qu'on va chercher à limiter
toutes les les molécules qui
sont la cause de la perte de
biodiversité donc c'est ces deux
élémentsl qu'il faut qu'on prenne en
compte parce que tu l'as dit et et c'est
la vérité bah aujourd'hui le cuivre les
quantités de cuivres qui sont utilisé il
faut savoir qu'il y a eu un débat on est
quelquefois sur la viticulture à 6 kg
les tard
euh il faudrait descendre à 4 kg
euh les les zones de viticulture vont
peut-être devenir des des des zones de
de mineris de cuive bientôt hein et la
bougie bordelaise vieille histoire elle
retrouve là une limite et il faut quand
même qu'on soit capable de se le dire la
bio a un sens beaucoup plus vaste qui
est le lien avec la terre la
qualité organolptique des produits le
contexte général mais je pense que sur
le NODU si j'ai voilà ça c'est déjà une
conclusion il faut qu'on réfléchisse à
un autre indicateur regardez ce qui se
passe au niveau européen pour
s'harmoniser aussi puisquon est tout
seul à avoir ces trois indicateurs
Dominique mais ça il faut vraiment qu'on
fasse un effort de recherche
là ah ben super ah vraiment et c'était
dans le plan écopyo 2 he on n pas eu le
temps mais ça je considère que ça doit
être un des éléments ça c'est le premier
point le deuxème sur
les les petites productions qui ne
trouvent pas de de de solution à à des à
des
problématiques
phytosanitaires c'est le sujet que
j'évoqué tout à l'heure c'estàd que les
industriels s'intéressent ça vaut aussi
dans la médecine hein les les maladies
orphelines c'est typiquement ce type de
sujet personne s'y intéresse parce que
derrière il y a pas de marché donc là
c'est la responsabilité de l'État qui
doit à ce moment-là fixer des règles
pour faire en sorte que dans en toute
production en plus quand vous me parlez
de petite production la moutarde c'est
quand même pas rien qui ont un rapport
avec l'istoire de la France qui on doit
avoir dans les industriels une
responsabilité qui est de trouver là des
solutions alors elle sont peut-être
chimiques mais elles peuvent être autres
que chimiques parce que la moutarde a
des particularités des propriétés qui
sont très intéressantes mais c'est sûr
que là il doit y avoir une décision de
l'État sinon c'est pas l'économie qui va
solutionner le problème je vous l'ai dit
et vous l'avez parfaitement dit sur
l'anèe euh je l'ai dit la décision
politique ça a été rappelé par Monsieur
le Président c'est vrai que l'arbitrage
entre le risque et le bénéfice à la fin
il est politique et c'est pour ça que si
l'anè a une responsabilité dans la les
autorisations de mise en marché de
manière continue le risque bénéfice dans
une société c'est un débat politique
quel est le risque qu'on accepte pour
quel bénéfice ça ça reste politique et
c'est pour ça que quand ce qu'on
lorsqu'on a transféré un laneste dans la
loi d'avenir reste les possibilités de
retrait qui sont de la responsabilité
politique parce que c'est à nous de
mesurer dans un débat démocratique quel
est le risque est accepté par la société
ou pas et quel est le bénéfice qu'on
cherche à en tirer et c'est pour ça que
je reviens sur la question du nu le
bénéfice c'est développer la
biodiversité et éviter de laisser des
molécules qui sont euh extrêmement euh
permanentes dans l'environnement c'est
pas possible c'était la question
d'ailleurs des néonécotinoïdes moi j'ai
interdit les néonécotinoïdes pour les
plantes à fleurs puisque avait été
montré par l'anèe que ces plantes à
fleurs ça avait un impact sur les
abeilles directes et c'était précis donc
sur le colza il y a plus de néoncotinoli
alors qu'ils étaient extrêmement
utilisés avant en tout cas moi c'est ce
que j'avais interdit après de manière
globale les néonicotinoïdes le vrai
débat sur l'interdiction c'est
effectivement la permanence ou la
persistance de trac de dans les sols qui
avaent justifié l'interdiction donc on
est bien là sur le sujet qu'il faut
qu'on
traite et l'an et la
science je all dire dans nos sociétés
démocratiques sont contesté puisque le
débat et ça vaut pour tous les sujets
ils sont sociaux ils sont politiques ils
sont scientifiques s'essentialisent on
cherche plus à
regarder ce qu'est le risque et le
bénéfice on est vraiment sur une logique
qui est extrêmement directe et qui porte
pour ceux qui défendent une manière
d'essentialisation du de la
problématique je vais prendre la
question du glyphosate puisque c'est
c'est le sujet et T les journalistes
aujourd'hui avec l'autorisation sur 10
an et ce que disait tout à l'heure un
député sur les techniques de
conservation des sols qu'on a beaucoup
cherché à regarder à étudier à
développer pour ce qui nous concerne il
est certain que ces techniques
développent du stockage de carbone et de
la matière organique dans les sols
développent de la biodiversité dans les
sols c'est certain mais que les
adventistes et une partie des plantes
invasives ne trouvent plus de
destruction par le labour puisque on est
sur des couvertures de sol et des semis
sur sur couverture et donc il y a de la
part des agriculteurs qui produisent ces
techniques l'idée que ils ont besoin
encore de glyphosate mais quand je dis
qu'ils ont besoin de glyphosate faut
savoir que on a eu jusqu'à 6 5 lit à
l'hectare fut un temp glyphosate quand
on est dans les techniques de
conservation on est sur au maximum 1 L
voire un 2 l et pas tous les ans donc on
est plus du tout dans le même
rapport et dans les mêmes conséquences
faut-il accepter que dans une phase de
transition parce que il y a des les
possibilités ensuite de se passer du
glyphosate et de plus en plus que
scientifiquement le débat politique
puisse s'appuyer sur des règles
scientifique combien j'en utilise
qu'est-ce que est nécessaire pour que
j'ai un bénéfice en terme de
biodiversité et de stockage de carbone
et de baisse de la consommation
énergétique fossile en particulier par
le fait que moins travailler le sol
c'est moins utiliser le tracteur c'est
moins consommer d'énergie ça c'est un
bénéfice je regarde par rapport au
risque qui est pris par le glyphosate
date à quelle quantité ce risque est
réduit à une expression qui est
négligeable parce que c'est ça le sujet
voire pour enclencher une transition à
la fin à s'en passer puisque certains
agriculteurs aujourd'hui même dans les
systèmes de couverture sous couverts
végétaux se passe du glyphosate donc
quand je dis la science on a besoin d'y
revenir oui parce que faut quand même
qu'on arrive à objectiver le le le
politique doit garder
l'objectif la science doit nous donner
des moyens mais le vrai débat il est sur
l'objectif et c'est là qu'en politique
quelquefois les objectifs qu'on doit
poursuivre de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique de redressement
de la biodiversité se heurte à des
constats scientifiques qui ne sont pas
partagés parce que pour certains
l'objectif c'est pas forcément
d'atteindre ce que je disais mais c'est
en tout cas de ne plus avoir en
l'occurrence du clyphosac de ne plus
avoir de néonicotque de ne plus avoir
telle etou telle chose pour régler un
problème est-ce qu'on peut imaginer une
dynamique qui règle le problème en même
temps qu'on a pas obligé de passer par
l'interdiction c'est ça le sujet et là
on a besoin de la science et je trouve
que le procès qui est fait à l'anesse
quand je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
par exemple sur le Cruiser
OSR je l'ai interdit c'est sur un
rapport de l'anè et ça a protégé les
abeilles à l'époque c'était une bonne
nouvelle bon ben quand l'anèe fait
quelque chose de bien faut pas être
uniquement dans l'idée que de toute
façon elle fera quelque chose de mal
l'ancest doit donner un avis voilà et
après le PO doit trancher monsie le
Président vous avez parfaitement raison
mais ça reste un débat politique au sens
c'est l'engagement de chacun
politiquement qui
compte que si vous voulez si vous êtes
pris uniquement sur les débats à chaque
fois sans avoir fixé l'objectif que vous
voulez atteindre c'est sûr que vous
pouvez laisser passer plein de choses et
dire que l'an décide à ma place ben non
si on a l'objectif les décisions de
l'ANC doivent correspondre à l'objectif
ça ça change tout ça c'est la politique
voilà je pense que je vais m'arrêter là
j'ai déjà beaucoup parlé en tout cas je
vous remercie de m'avoir invité en tout
cas c'est nous qui vous remercions
Monsieur le Ministre pour la qualité de
cette audition des échanges personnel
j'ai beaucoup apprécié la clarté la
simplicité la sincérité de vos
réponses je lève cette séance nous nous
retrouvons la semaine prochaine je sa
plus la date mais vous recev les
convocations bonne journée à
tous